The Association of Southeast Asian Nations, more commonly known as ASEAN,...
...marked its 50th anniversary last year.
ASEAN was born out of the superpower rivalry...
...between the U.S. and the then Soviet Union.
It was founded during the height of the Vietnam War by five countries:...
...Thailand, Indonesia, the Philippines, Singapore and Malaysia.
Its purpose was to promote stability...
...and contain the influence of communism during the Cold War.
After the Cold War ended, five other countries,...
...Brunei, Vietnam, Laos, Cambodia and Myanmar joined,...
...rounding off the 10 members of ASEAN today.
For instance, Indonesia represents nearly 40% of the region's economic output,...
...while the GDP per capita of Singapore, the highest in the 10,...
...is 24 times higher than that of the lowest, Cambodia.
But as a group, ASEAN is a powerhouse,...
...the sixth largest economy in the world, on par with the United Kingdom...
...and ahead of France and India.
It's poised to be the world's growth engine...
...as ASEAN countries like Vietnam and the Philippines...
...boast phenomenal growth rates.
ASEAN has the world's third largest labor force...
...of more than 600 million people, behind China and India,...
...but ahead of the EU and U.S.
More than half of the ASEAN's population is below 30 years old...
...and they love going online with their mobile phones.
Southeast Asians spend more time on the mobile internet...
...than anyone else on the planet.
That's why tech giants like Google, Facebook and Alibaba...
...are scrambling for a share of ASEAN's digital economy...
...forecasted to grow to 200 billion by 2025.